foreign
[Applause]
that's enough
you shut up over there
happy Thursday I believe it's Thursday
so there's a curious sickness going
around and for once it's not kill me
but there seems to be no cure I've got a
good cultural dementia an Affliction
that seems to come over the Democrat
media class whenever one of their latest
causes goes south
and by itself that includes fleeing New
York for Florida
yeah so whatever they get is contagious
spreading faster than whoopee's legs in
a hotel pool
[Applause]
there is a backstory to that joke so it
wasn't just some kind of indiscriminate
disgusting comment she did claim that
she liked to have sex in pools so uh
direct your letters to that her for that
image
sorry do you remember the Duke lacrosse
scandal
uh well you're not supposed to that's uh
when a bunch of white Frat Boys were
accused of raping a black stripper
predictably the media went wild the only
problem was it never happened the only
person who ended up going to jail was
the prosecutor oh and the stripper she's
in jail for murder and worse she never
writes back
how about the coveting kids remember
that when those Catholic kids were
portrayed as racist for hassling a naked
Native American man I almost said a
naked American man that would have been
more interesting but then video turned
up showing that he was actually hassling
them first and he turned out to be a
Serial liar claiming Vietnam vet status
when Jane Fonda spent more time overseas
than he did
I assumed after that the media would
learn their lesson but then there's
Jesse and then the media fell back in
line pushing there two on the nose
manicured hoaxes then came Russian
collusion in Hunter's laptop I could go
on and on and on but I don't want to
bump Fox and Friends first and shock all
their meth head viewers
but there's another big bad memory they
want you to forget but yet it still
lingers like a fart in a shower
and it's because of its horrible
consequences of course defunding the
police it started with the squad the
birthplace of all mentally deranged
ideas and at the time of course the left
in their media lap dogs loved it
remember Kamala offering to bail out
rioters during 2020 Summer of Love it's
the last time she ever did anything of
accomplishment BLM raised enough money
to put thousands of cops on patrol
instead that money went to mansions and
swimming pools yes it was going to be a
Brave New World where we all just got
along where criminals helped little old
ladies cross the street instead of
knocking their teeth out and taking
their purses
but then a funny thing happened or not
so funny depending on your ZIP code
reality came turns out defunding was the
worst idea since Hunter said hey let's
record this
let's go la Chicago Philly Baltimore St
Louis New York our major cities look
scarier than the entire cast of The View
waking up on a Sunday morning
our police academies became as empty as
a freshly looted Walgreens and the
Subways as gross as Johnny Depp's teeth
and it wasn't just major cities in
Goodhue Minnesota recently the entire
police department resigned granted it's
six people but still
and right on cue just as this chaos
becomes an election issue Democratic
memory loss returns suddenly we're told
they didn't mean to fund yeah what you
didn't think we were serious did you
those were just the weirdos from the
squad
which is like the mob blaming their
Hitmen they do your ugly work so your
hands look squeaky clean
blame the squad but don't be fooled
nothing's changed today we've just got
defunded by different means call it soft
defunded bail reform has meant that
shoplifting just passed pickleball as
the nation's fastest growing sport
true I mean it's easier on the knees
unless you're carrying a flat screen and
of course our Board of security is about
as reliable as Brian stelter's food
diary our downtown looks like scenes
from the Afghanistan withdrawal or Worse
cat's office
[Music]
you weren't supposed to catch me wearing
this blanket
[Music]
so what's the solution is it all gonna
get better how about this for an honest
answer no this is it it's the new normal
and it's about as normal as Rachel
Levine singing I Am Woman hear me roar
meaning The New Normal used to be the
old abnormal
it's flipped thanks to the mentally ill
and delusional left so if you live in a
city and you're okay with that fine but
if not you got two options you can fight
back you know like these guys did or
like Daniel penny
or you could end up like Daniel Penny
you know you'll be the one who ends up
with felony charges
then that leaves option two which is to
leave because frankly I'm out of ideas
but if you have an idea you can use the
suggestion box we do have one you know
if someone hasn't stolen it
[Applause]
tonight
he was the inspiration for Dockers
co-host of fox and friends first Todd
Pyro
she causes more trigger warnings than
Alec Baldwin Deputy opinion editor at
Newsweek by younger and Sargon
she's like Snow White usually comatose
and surrounded by dwarves Fox News
contributor
and steroids take him to get stronger my
massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
foreign
Todd how you doing Dockers huh yeah yeah
that is so accurate when I was a like a
teenager I used to wear Dockers how
uncool can you be as a teenager to wear
Dockers it's good to see you've grown
out of that uncool face my goal every
time I'm on your show is to dress like
we are going to the Realtors convention
yes exactly we shouldn't accomplish
we're letting it Loose let's leave our
wedding rings in the hotel room shall we
all right
just kidding honey
progressives to continue is to divorce
reality from their policies right the
media helps them but if they were to
analyze the consequences of their
policies they would commit suicide
journalists at their core are supposed
to be storytellers and stories are
supposed to have a beginning a middle
and an end the mainstream media in their
zest to promote their far left agenda
they don't tell the end of the story in
your in your monologue right Duke
lacrosse we don't know the end of that
story if you're just watching the
mainstream media the end of the story is
is really unfortunate for the Duke
lacrosse players because they were found
innocent but if you say Duke lacrosse
everybody thinks oh they're rapists
think of that that Scourge that's on
those individuals for the rest of their
lives and that's the problem because if
you're watching Fox you got the end of
the story if you watch the other guys
you didn't yeah that's true that's true
you know I just don't see how any of
this can get any better if if no one in
power Minds that it's getting worse
because it the sad thing is the only
people that really hear the end of the
story are people that watch Fox what do
you make of this well this looks like
it's a story about politics right about
a political divide in this country left
versus right but the truth is this is
not just you know the media being
liberal and being in the pocket of the
Democrats which they are this is class
Warfare okay let's call it what it is
siding with criminals over their victims
siding with Jesse Smollett right this is
the kind of thing that you do when you
see yourself as on the other side of the
middle class right this is class Warfare
against the working class you said it
exactly perfectly The New Normal right
because they are waging more on the
middle class from an economic point of
view and they're Waging War on the
middle class from a values point of view
siding with criminals over their victims
over and over and over again and it's
just terrible it's you know it
it's terrible but not for them that's
the secret is that they're not they're
not feeling it the people that they
claim to defend are the people that live
in these cities their life sucks but
like the people that are for these
policies there they got private security
they're good they could do this to the
very end that's the real class
distinction now between the people they
claim to defend and the people that are
destroying their lives tax
foreign
that's all I have I could take it from
here I know you can yeah I'm a
professional I with a shawl no less I
think that all of this too is that these
stories they really wanted them to be
true so badly that they were willing to
overlook a lot of red flags like the
Jesse Smollett story if you just hear
that story there's several things along
the way where you're like was that
really he was out getting Subway and it
was the cold and all that stuff but they
they want it to be true because if it's
their narrative and they so they just
kind of Overlook it which I mean you as
humans that's something we can do I did
it a lot in my 20s with like every
relationship that I had yeah you know
it's like you go to the guy's apartment
where are you it's so late he tells you
that he was just at Subway yeah if you
don't want to see the truth you will
probably believe him yeah no I think I
think in both sides I hate to say this
but both sides do this I think that
absolutely the right has done that when
it comes to like you know the War on
Drugs but I I just don't see them coming
close to this weird dementia where every
bad thing that happens somehow doesn't
exist Tyrus well Greg and I I didn't
tell you this earlier because I don't
ever want to see the clip again okay but
what your monologue is basically giving
roots to is you remember the wonderful
dinner Don Lemon and Alfredo Cuomo had
together yes where they were in New York
City and it was a lovely evening yes it
was lovely it's no crime yeah and people
even walked by and said hey Dom he's
like hi this place is wonderful so
that's how the world is because that's
how they see it so of course there
should be no bail because when I'm
outside there's no problems it's all
lollipops and gumdrops so that's how
they project the world
and that's and then they say it's the
group so therefore they are doing it for
because their life is great so when they
project this
because they are in a situation where
they can go to nice meals and I'm pretty
sure there was a security guy sitting
over there and they were and they had
car service to get there he's only had
to walk through the streets to get where
they're going so until they experience
something and then when they do have
something happen to them then they're
the world's biggest victim of all time
and they can't believe it and they will
say but they still won't go back on them
it wasn't them this was an isolated
incident that a couple of eggs cracked
that's what this is really about the
everything's fine when you see 25 kids
and hoodies robbing a store that's like
a unicorn yeah
it never happened I don't I don't you
know yeah my favorite part of that
interview too is Don Lemon speaking of
Never Happened being like people were
coming up and saying thank you for what
you did like that that's gonna be some
kind of like purple heart veteran
nobody's thinking that's how it is in
Candyland Candyland is beautiful thank
you for your service yeah thank you for
your service Don Lemon that's how they
all think that's how they all act and
that's how they they tell themselves
because when they get walk in the mirror
at their house their lights are on their
bills are paid you know they're checking
to see how many likes they got in
Twitter Life is Beautiful for them
because of the situation they're in so
when they project that on everyone who's
like no it's not I have three crackheads
getting it on and I don't work for
PornHub
but that's not what the job of the
journalist is supposed to be that we've
got is to tell their truth get it
together
which is which is fancy for flying yeah
but I think that people are on to that
you know
the point you're making is going to be a
great tease to our next segment we'll
start we're starting to understand that
everything that we're told that is
supposed to be true
see what I did there yeah
my fingers are doing push-ups uh these
things that are true really aren't at
all
does that make you want to stick around
for the next next segment I'm sticking
around Greg ah damn it hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else